[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
has meaning we help them to create and
have actual real relationships george
campbell ramsey personality and host of
the
better or the fine print podcast and the
entree leadership podcast is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple a eight two
five five two two five shannon starts
off this hour in carlsbad new mexico hi
shannon how are you good how are you
dave better than i deserve what's up
good
so i'm calling because i have a 2019
suburban that literally broke down on
the side of the road in the middle of
nowhere about two months ago
i finally found out that it needs a new
engine it's under warranty
and basically we are getting nowhere
with gm and finding out
an answer on when we will get a new
engine um
i have a friend that owns a body shop
where we live
and i kind of said hey can you give us
some advice when do you think we would
possibly get a new engine because we're
getting nowhere with gm
he said let me make a few phone calls
and get back to you and basically said
i would start shopping for new vehicles
so here we are unplanned
trying to figure out should we wait
you know possibly the three four however
many months
to get my vehicle back since it is under
warranty it's completely paid for uh
you know we have the cash to pay for the
difference for a new vehicle but it's
just not the ideal time we weren't
planning on getting a new vehicle at all
now on a crummy time to buy a car right
now
it's terrible
i'm sorry what a mess
so when you talk to the general motors
folks what are they telling you
so there
they it's basically a back and forth of
you know my husband's at this point
trying to see where we are in line
you know we could be 30 in line we could
be 900 in line and so they told us last
week you know we'll get back to you we
still haven't heard back
it's basically going nowhere
well it's going somewhere based on the
size of the foot you put on their butt
true that's true they said they would
try to escalate it but that's who knows
if they actually might actually escalate
for them
so yeah you know i call the general
manager of the dealership and explain to
them you're getting ready to hire an
attorney
okay because they're not they're not
honoring their warranty and you being
without a car is not okay
and you know let's jack them up
because this is i'm guessing this is a
supply chain problem because it's not
general motors dna to be this uh
uncooperative usually they're very good
about stuff
yes and they basically are blaming
everything on covet and
supply chain they can't get an engine
out of the dead gum factory
well i'm going to be calling them every
day for updates to you're the squeaky
wheel who gets the grease and on top of
that i'm going to go to the dealership
and say you're going to let me use a car
until this is fixed and you're going to
do it for free oh there's a good idea
yeah we've tried we've tried doing that
we've tried getting a loan i don't have
any cars again
yeah they said they don't have any
loaners because of covid and the the
hard part about it is too is that we
live
in the middle of nowhere and our car is
in el paso texas two hours away so it's
not a thing you know where we can go in
there every day we have been on the
phone with um
you know the person in the
shop every day but basically that's
where they escalated it to gm
corporate and my husband's been in
communication with them yeah i think i'm
going to be in touch with the regional
corporate guy and so you guys need to
get me a loan or i'm with george on that
that's a brilliant idea
and guys we understand that you got
supply chain problems but you need to
understand i also don't have a car
yes and so that's a bigger deal for me
than your supply chain problems
so get me a car exactly give me a car
yeah i'll be real understanding if you
get me a car bring me a car
okay so i think just like bring me a car
now
okay yeah that's that's what we've been
trying to do and then yeah i know but i
i think you're being what we're saying
is we think you're being too nice
yeah
channel your inner dave ramsey when you
show up
i know well and that's why we're going
back and forth and you know we've been
saying you know should we just go get a
different car because this is the second
major issue that we've had with this car
if you want to sell it that's fine sell
solid after it's fixed but in the
meantime they should provide you a car
if you if you if you jack everybody up
you still don't get a car and you still
don't get an engine and you've got the
money i guess you're going to have to go
buy a car aren't you
i know and then sell that one when it
gets fixed right
yes and that's what i that's another
thing because they're lowballing us
because we've tried to say hey what
would you give us for this and they're
lowballing us and
we do have the money to go we are in a
very blessed situation where just go buy
a car and then get that car fixed and
get it sold
if you can't get a loaner
and i really am going to be talking to
the regional guys i've actually had two
people work for me over there that used
to be general motors regional
customer
uh service reps and so they had regional
guys and i don't know if they still do
or not but that was a few years back but
uh and honestly they are trained
like no other to make customers happy
now i understand they can't make cars or
engines appear out of thin air but uh
but they can uh if you make it a big
enough deal and go listen i really don't
want to go legal on you guys but i'm
getting ready to hire an attorney
and we're gonna make you guys wish you
would loan me a car
yeah i agree because i'm at the point
where i'm i'm almost don't even want to
buy another gm vehicle ever yeah well i
mean you can tell them that too i mean
that that's understandable and the sad
thing is they make great cars i've owned
them all my life but um
yeah
you know
it it it is what it is but here's the
thing
companies out there listening
you have legitimate supply chain issues
but your customer has legitimate
problems and your job as the company
solve the customer problem they don't
really care about your problem
they don't really care
yeah and a big part of this is to
realize you have options it's when you
realize well we gotta go get a new car
because i'm going to be beating down
their door until we have a solution here
and the worst worst case is we get a
temporary car we resell it and hopefully
we don't lose any money drive the car or
buy the car you want to replace it with
and direct and then sell the
suburban when you get it fixed that's
fine that's the answer too you got the
money to do that it's just inconvenient
and you shouldn't have to
you shouldn't have to they should they
should take care of you so and i got a
feeling if you lean in hard enough and
often enough that probably you're going
to get that result
that was a good fix george that's a good
thing i always start with kindness and
then i get a little more firm when
things aren't going the way they should
and uh it's a hard thing to do with
customer service a lot of people have a
hard time
you know being the being bad cop yeah
well i don't yeah i don't want to just
start in chewing somebody out yeah but
we do need to you know click up click up
click up the heat as we go along and um
i mean you know if the food's not coming
from the kitchen it's like
hello
been an hour we need some food
you know and
we've talked about this a couple times
now do i need to talk to a manager how
can i help you yeah you need me to go
back there and help you cook i mean
what's the deal i would love to see you
back here in the kitchen food needs to
come out of the kitchen baby you can
grill
this happened the other day i'm just
saying this is the ramsay shop
[Music]
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
we've taught gods and grandma's ways of
handling money for 30 years here at
ramsey and now my good friend and expert
dr john deloney is paving the way for
how we talk about relationships and
mental health his brand new book own
your past change your future has been on
sale now for eight days it's available
for purchase and it's a book everyone
needs to read it has personally changed
the language i use with others it's
changed me it changed george who knew
there we go this book is not just for
people who are healing from some
terrible traumatic experience the
practical steps packed in here apply to
everyone in every walk of life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old who's out of
college and looking to make friends the
mom and dad who want to connect with
their grown kids better or their young
kids better
people coming out of abusive
relationships everyone every one of you
listening right now has a story
john took his two phds his 20 years of
counseling experience have packed it
into an easy to understand book pick up
your copy of own your past change your
future today for only 20 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com
don't miss this lori is in chicago hi
lori welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i am going to court tomorrow for credit
card debt
a
the credit card original company sold it
to a debt buyer
and now the lawyer is suing me
and i tried settling two times
and they really wouldn't go down very
much it's original that is 8 500
and they went down as far as 59.85
i was just wondering if you had any
ideas of what it could do as far as
facing
a lawyer tomorrow or if i still try to
call this company that's not working
with me they wanted me to make payments
and i know you're not for that yeah i
wouldn't do that it doesn't work out
well for you
um the lump sum settlement is the only
way to go have you got the money to
settle tomorrow
no not no i don't have that much i tried
settling um i can give them 2300. how
much do you get
2 300. okay what was the original debt
uh
85.50 that was the original debt
not what they say you owe
i'm not sure how how that exactly works
how much did you borrow how much was
owed when you quit paying it
well it went through another collection
agency was sold again so no no no that's
not what i'm asking i'm asking when you
quit paying the credit card
how much was owed
um
sorry years ago
um
nine i believe it was nine thousand
seven hundred and sixty six dollars no i
was making perfect no it wouldn't have
gone down
well i made i was making payments to
original cred
okay all right
well they probably as you've heard on
the show probably paid a nickel on the
dollar for it
right so they probably got five six
hundred bucks in this dad
um can you get any more together than
2500
well i have some save for my
my
taxes on my house
i mean
i'm very
limited maybe 3 000 okay all right
or maybe if you used a little bit of
that tax money if you get rid of this
it's worth it okay if you go to 3 500 or
4 000 and you get rid of an eight or ten
thousand dollar debt it's going to be
worth it so here's what's gonna happen
all right when you go into court on a
debt this size
you it's um very similar
this is not high drama
with matlock or some big high-powered
whatever you think of attorney on some
television show okay this is more like
going to traffic court when you got a
ticket that time
you ever done that
not that but i've done something else
okay you've gone to a court when it was
like a big yawn
and it was all like a conveyor belt and
it was automatic and nobody cared
and there was no drama and there was no
shaming and there was nothing legal it
was just boom clip clip clip you're out
of there
that's what this is going to be
i
heard you once say to um try to find the
lawyer ahead of time yes and to make a
deal then in the hall yeah
otherwise walk up in front of the judge
and tell the judge you've tried to make
a deal
and you know that this is a debt buyer
and you know that they paid a nickel on
the dollar for it approximately because
that's under industry standard and i'm
standing here offering this guy three
thousand dollars and we can't get him to
take it your honor
and he's gonna shame the attorney then
because you're going to be the only
human that showed up on this whole thing
this guy's got 200 cases all of them are
on automatic smackdown and no humans
show up except old laurie and there she
stands
so you're going to be like the
entertainment for the morning
right
do they care about any of my
no
no
nothing they don't care about your story
they don't think don't care if you're
pitiful they don't care yeah
best thing it's just money okay it's
just very awkward very agnostic
there's no spirit to it there's no
morals to it it's just i want some money
and if you give me some money oh and i
don't like the money and then the you
tell the judge and here's the money and
the judge goes oh come on
it's going to sound like that it's going
to be like judge judy or something in
here right
okay you don't think that the lawyer
will or i mean the judge will say that
make payments he might
he might he might slap you with a
garnishment i don't know it's possible
but you don't have a lot of options here
your only option is settle it if you
can't settle it ask the judge to settle
it otherwise he's going he's going to
make you do something because he's going
to do that anyway
right if you don't show up they're going
to get a judgment and they're going to
begin to garnish you
yeah i'll show up
okay but i'm just saying if you don't
show you automatically lose but by the
way you're in the wrong so you're
automatically going to lose anyway
i know the only question is can you just
you know by by being a human and being
there do you influence the process and
get a settlement
but you got really no defense you owe
the debt you didn't pay it there's no
defense
how old is this debt
it was from um well these guys purchased
it in 2020 when did you know okay
the last time i paid so it's a few years
old
18 2018. okay and what was it originally
what kind of credit card
uh the name of the credit card
was capital one okay all right
yeah they'll sue you on ten thousand
bucks they usually won't screw with it
on under five because it's not worth
their legal hassle
but the debt buyers sometimes will screw
with it if they buy it under five
and so
yeah this is a pretty substantial
account most debt is under five thousand
dollars per card
but good old capital one what's in your
wallet lawsuits
apparently man i haven't i haven't heard
a lot of situations where people are
going to court over the credit card debt
it doesn't happen very often it's
usually they just deal with the debt
settlement companies and they try to you
know negotiate the debt buyer will
usually settle and again folks they're
buying these things a nickel on the
dollar um
and you know we did this oh yeah
christmas before last week we paid off a
bunch a day yeah we bought 10 million
dollars worth of debt
from um from
a lot of it was medical debt
and uh we we bought 10 million dollars
for a quarter on our for two and a half
percent paid 250 000 for it and we call
we had all of our uh eight our employees
get we gave them eight each it was like
um what uh there was like uh 10 000
accounts roughly
and uh they each called and told people
for christmas that their debt was
forgiven
so we bought 10 million dollars worth
and forgave it
and it was our christmas it's what it's
what we did for christmas yeah we had
our products our favorite and it was a
blast but we bought that for 250 000 is
10 million a little north of 10 million
dollars so that's that's 25 cents on i
mean that's two and a half cents on the
dollar yeah we bought the whole book
there's the proof i mean now that was
old medical debt which is that by the
way it's usually cheaper to buy yeah
than on credit cards there's some car
loans in there too i remember calling
someone saying we paid off yeah we got a
few credit cards in there i think we got
i think we probably got i don't know a
couple of hundred credit cards in there
but most of it was medical but so you
you can buy debt for a nickel on the
dollar and then go try to collect it um
anything they make over that is profit
yeah we didn't collect it we just sent
them all letters and a lot of them
thought we were scamming them oh yeah no
one believed me when i called they said
what i didn't ask you to do so fun we
got some great videos there were some
inspiring ones too a lot of people just
broke down and cried yeah it was sweet
but some people were just angry with me
yeah why are you calling me i'm busy
okay sorry sir have a good day just
calling to tell you you don't owe the
debt anymore what i didn't ask you to do
that are you doing who
what are you the grinch it's christmas
oh my gosh too funny it's a blast so
yeah that's the truth and so you can you
can buy debt like that and if you want
to write big checks anyway and so
that's kind of proof that what we're
saying is true that you can buy it for a
nickel on there which is why they're
probably going to go
in the dollar on it and this is uh good
old citibank at your service
just think of that next time you see one
of those stupid buck commercials of
theirs this is the ramsay show
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage courtney is with
us hi courtney how are you i'm doing
great dave how are you i am better than
i deserve it's so i'd love to hear that
where do you live i live in houston
texas good fun welcome to nashville yes
all right how much debt have you paid
off i paid off 113
hundred and seventy four dollars i love
it and how long did that take it took me
30 months good and your range of income
during that between 74 000 to 90 000.
cool what do you do for a living i am a
director of marketing i work in real
estate
good good and uh what kind of debt was
your hundred and fourteen thousand so
most of it about 94 000 of it was from
student loan debt and the rest was for
my car loan okay cool yeah what'd you
get your degree in i got my degree in
health science and biology it was
totally different from what my career is
that's okay yeah now you're making money
life's good yes and you paid it off
that's the other thing that's good so
good for you so how long you've been out
of school i've been out of school oh my
god i graduated in 2012 so it's been a
really long
time eight eight nine years yeah all
right but but two and a half years ago
bing bing what happened okay so i've
been getting these mails from my you
know from fed loans and you owe money
you owe money and i was talking to my
friend and she was like courtney just
look at it as a debt you'll pay for the
rest of your life
that's so pro that's so hopeful what
good friends
and i was like yeah i want better than
that so i came across your youtube
channel and i've been hooked ever since
i purchased the total money makeover i
listened to podcasts i mean i was hooked
on you um and i got debt-free because of
unicef thank you for that well thank you
way to go you did the work yeah you're
impressive that's yeah we're about the
same age i graduate graduated the same
year with a lot less debt than you but
was that a slog to get through
it was it was a slog i had to really use
that dead snowball method to really take
it piece by piece because looking at it
full-on i was terrified i was like i'll
never get it done but
doing it smaller by smaller it helped me
really accomplish that goal yeah when
you look at that debt and you're like i
don't even make that much how am i ever
going to make these payments and you
started doing the debt snowball was
there a moment where you were like oh
this is working i see the progress yeah
i think my third or fourth loan i paid
off i was like okay i can do this
chucking along and i had my mini
victories for those ones that i did pay
off so it made it much better getting to
the final destination that's fun what
was those mini victories did you
celebrate in some way i did celebrate i
might have bought a pair of shoes or
something small sorry dave you know i
wasn't on rice and beans the whole time
but i just had to you know give myself a
little treat show self-moments yeah yeah
so i had to do that for myself well you
were very reasonable yeah i might
celebrate but it wouldn't be shoes not
shoes
but that's you know ken coleman he would
bite you yeah definitely would
definitely for sure oh that's awesome
congratulations thank you thank you who
was your biggest cheerleader my biggest
was um my parents were really good my
family um my boyfriend terence he was
great helping me out a lot all the way
so yeah and you clearly had some
detractors there does your friend now go
wait you did it did you take your whole
life yeah another like well courtney can
you tell me more about this debt
snowball method who is this dave ramsey
person so i'm just putting them all
drinking the kool-aid of dave ramsey so
you just put debt free in the search bar
on youtube and there we were there you
were that's where you were that's how i
found you yeah oh my god so i mean
literally even like my passwords on my
computer was like debt free 2021 i
really wrote a vision and made it plain
and i stick to that habakkuk 3-3 i love
it yeah well done yeah write the vision
and make it plain okay that's good hey
when you do that something something
snaps when you write it down and you put
it right in front of you and you go okay
gotta do this and there's an
accountability that starts to work in
your brain that's really powerful and
then you tell people you're doing it and
they're like cheering you on you're like
i can't let them down yeah i mean even
on my vision board i wrote like a blank
check into my fed loan with the amount
to pay off and it's crazy that now it's
finally done so george
she has a vision board yes
she has a vision board that's like a
life hack that's amazing yeah yeah you
need it really good you don't need to
manifest it when you just write it down
and go i'm going to write this check one
day and it's going to feel so good to
have no payments in the world yeah i
love it how does it feel it feels great
it feels great to be finally free to
have no one calling me i mean i did work
another i worked two jobs and my
full-time job and i worked part-time at
amazon as a personal shopper i'm
listening to your show during code where
you're like hey get a part-time job
while you can so i did that and it
helped me a lot how much did they pay
you for that they were paying me about i
think about fifteen dollars an hour wow
that's rowdy yeah and you made your own
hours
all and you just check in check out um
no so i worked i worked in the store so
i was like literally literally in the
store oh wow yeah
oh my gosh so physically amazon did
something physical it was amazing except
the liver yeah this is an amazon store
no so it was amazon with whole foods so
you i would talk like at four in the
morning and i would like pick up
groceries for people and they would i've
been known to do that the amazon whole
foods delivery dave you have two hour
delivery you can't beat that
and it was free at the time george you
know we're we're a generation of
convenience dave george that's right i
know you went such a millennial dave
went uphill both ways he's not only
shopped at whole foods but i had them
deliver it george it's even more it
doesn't even
put to a dinosaur i'm sure rachel would
do that i'm sure rachel has done that
like today yeah for sure there's no
question
well that's awesome you were willing to
do whatever it took to get this thing
done well done proud of you thank you
how do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is um consistency
and having that discipline and the key
is like i said making uh writing a
vision making it plain yeah work at
whole foods instead of buy at whole
foods there you go
she got paid to be inside of a whole
foods yeah that's historic
yeah and walk out without buying
anything hello yeah whole paycheck
that's the place yeah okay wow good for
you i'm so proud of you all right we got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure you are definitely on
your way that's the next thing for the
vision board yes right millionaire stuff
anyway gang on game on game on game on i
love it very cool also copy a total
money makeover for you to give to your
friend who doesn't think she can do it
so maybe we can gang up on her and help
her do it
in a good way so good stuff
very very cool courtney you're a rock
star you're amazing we're so proud of
you thank you very well done all right
courtney from houston texas 114
thousand dollars paid off in two and a
half years 30 long
short months making 74-90 with the extra
job count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt-free
yeah
wow
reminds me that henry ford quote if you
think you can you think you can't you're
right you're right and she thought she
could and she was right
i don't know what happens in the human
spirit
or in the human brain when you write
something down
that means a lot to you not just
generally writing something down you go
okay i am going to lose
30 pounds in 90 days and you write it
out
as soon as you write it down something
snaps
i'm going to increase my income to 100
000 this year as soon as you write it
out and you actually believe it what you
can you know what you believe can
conceive and believe you can achieve
earl nightingale you should say
something happens it's not magic and
it's not it's not just the power of
positive thinking but there's something
about when you when your brain the
neural pathways when you get really
precise and concise and say this is my
desired future and then you your brain
automatically kicks into gear okay what
have i got to do to make that happen
it's a mix of science and spirit yeah a
little bit of both there a little
psychology a little brain magic but then
also it changes your spirit and you go
okay i'm going to do this it's for real
this time i'm not playing around and
that's exactly what courtney did yeah
she's she's powerful and you know she's
quoting a scripture from the old
testament habakkuk there back at 3 3 i
believe it is it says write the vision
and make it plain and so take your
vision write it out and this is not
again not hocus pocus and it's not just
goal setting is magical it's not it's
not magical unless you go do the work to
cause the thing to happen i mean if you
write down i'm going to lose 30 pounds
then you eat a bag of cookies 20 minutes
later probably not on track right so
well before i get started you know no no
so um it's a cash i don't know anybody
that's done that but um i could probably
do it yeah so you got to write this out
and
something happens or something your
brain just goes
and it starts focusing and all the
distractions out here the things that
were causing you to to bounce off the
walls and not hit your goals they start
to be minimized and the things that
cause you to hit your goals start to be
maximized there's something about it
yeah and so that and really you know
what a budget is
it's it's written goals yeah
written goals for the month that's all
it is you think you're gonna pay off
sallie mae for the rest of your life
you're probably right and if you think
you're gonna pay her off in two years
you're probably right it's amazing how
that works yep because you will find
your way at 4am into a whole foods to
pack groceries that's right this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so if you want to come on
the ramsay show in person here in the
lobby you want to visit the lobby come
visit anytime by the way sidebar
it's here in nashville our visitor
center is pretty stinking incredible all
kinds of timelines and wonderful things
you can enjoy the whole ramsay
experience here uh free homemade cookies
oh my gosh
and coffee and all kinds of stuff in our
snack bar we got a big bookstore area
and you can sit and watch the show if
you'd like it's taped in the afternoons
not taped it's live in the afternoons
and is also taped while we're doing it
live
from 1 to 4 central time so if you're in
the nashville area put us on your stop
we're a little bit south of nashville in
a wonderful town called franklin
tennessee now if you want to do your
debt-free scream on the phone you can do
that a lot of people do and but these
days a lot of people go oh the way i'm
going to celebrate debt freedom is i'm
going to make a trip to nashville
because it's a cool city and i want to
see the city and i'm going to use this
dave thing isn't it this ramsey thing is
an excuse for doing that so if you want
to do that you go george you need to go
the website and fill out what's going on
so what do you do ramsay solutions.com
debt free screen will take you straight
to the form to apply okay now the idea
of the debt-free scream
is two things one is it is a chance for
you to celebrate
the transformation
that has occurred in your life
and in the life of your family and we
want to celebrate that milestone with
you
also
we the the benefit of that is there's
probably a thousand or more now posted
on our youtube channel we put all the
all the debt free screams on the youtube
channel and so you can just sit and
watch them for days
uh but they're that your debt-free
scream is to motivate others to tell
other people that this can
be
done now this
when we say this george that's an
important qualification what is this
this is to become debt free and stay
debt-free yes
and so you've got to follow the plan to
a t and still be following it
to this day
which means
maybe you're not using a credit card
anymore maybe it means you're not
using a credit card anymore and so here
let me help you with this kelly just
told us at the break and we were just
flabbergasted that like uh one out of
three or so of you that apply to do your
debt free scream are still using credit
cards
let me tell you what happens
we throw you in the trash bin in the
ditch you don't we don't want to
motivate other people to be like you
we want to motivate people to be not
like you
and so um that's the whole thing get out
of debt stay out of debt you're not
using your stinking credit cards anymore
and you're not violating six other
things we teach around here you know uh
every day because that's not consistent
with we're trying to create a
transformed life here not just a simple
number that you paid off the debt and
then you're you know you're going to go
back in yeah the debt-free screams are
not for those that are dave ish that's
fine
yeah it's fine if you did that but we
just want to assist
we want to celebrate the people who
really made the sacrifices who had that
full 180 life transformation so there's
a series of questions when you go fill
out the form at
ramseysolutions.comfreescream and some
of those questions uh involve your
financial habits and so make sure that
you answer those honestly first of all
don't skirt around the process kelly
will sniff you out but we get thousands
of applications every year
you have to get quite a line to do your
debt-free screening and a lot of people
wanting to do it actually doing the
stuff
so we tell people to apply months ahead
of their debt-free date because there's
such a long line ahead of you but you're
going to get thrown out if you don't do
it the right way and like kelly
mentioned 40 of you
said i'm using a credit card still
and which means hey more room for the
other sixty percent yeah i'll follow the
plan and here's the thing it'll it'll
save you a lot of time to just not even
fill out the application because you're
not gonna be on okay
and well dave i don't like that well
then get your own radio show this is
mine
so um and i get to do what i want it
says ramsay on it
isn't that magic so um it's not fair
yeah that's it
so you can do your own debt free scream
on your own youtube channel yeah that
works too make it up just just jump out
there and all six of your followers and
they can they can see you do it so
um but if you want to do it here we're
going to celebrate the proper kind of
life transformation that sticks and that
is generational and everything's going
through so no credit card use and uh you
know don't be issuing the stuff we talk
about don't because
what we want to encourage people to be
it's not that we're mad at you well
you're just being snobbish no we have a
very
dialed in purpose for this it's to
motivate people to do
things that
we teach and have taught for 30 years
because they work because they're good
for you
um it's you know
and it's kind of unsatisfying for us to
sit and watch you half do stuff so we
don't want to do that but dave we're
missing out on the debt-free screams
where they go dave the way i got
debt-free was my credit card points yeah
that's how i did it i missed that i
borrowed from the 401k dave that's how i
got debt-free yeah i borrowed my way out
of that that's how i got debt free
yeah this is these all these things come
up believe it or not so there's some
clarification for you and um
kelly is uh
world-renowned for being able to figure
out if you're lying or not
um she's like it's like scary she's got
a pretty good bs meter
she's looking at me right now i think i
failed
ramsay solutions.com you're a little
intimidated are you okay good that's
good all right chris is with us
cleveland ohio hi chris what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'll
try to be as brief as possible
my question is my wife and i over the
last two and a half years have really
focused in on the steps
and have been in a situation where now
we financially were able to pay off the
house
last fall
we have no credit card debt
and it seems to me at this point where
our income levels are she had recently
gotten promoted about two years ago
that now we're getting just absolutely
at the end of the year crushed and
having to write big checks for taxes
and i guess my question is i mean is is
potentially looking into
an llc with some rental properties even
something that should be on the table to
even look at
well an llc doesn't change the taxes at
all you can own the rental property in
your personal name
yeah well tax wise it doesn't change the
taxes one bit protection-wise it's good
to put rental property in there from a
risk management standpoint somebody
falls and breaks their face
on that property then they can sue only
the owner of that property which happens
to not be you have to be an llc so they
don't come take your personal vehicle so
from a risk management standpoint i no
longer own anything
i'm completely poor
a company that i own owns everything you
know so i've got this stack of llc's
that's ridiculous my cars are even owned
by llc's now so um but that's just
because you know i'm now i'm at a point
that i'm a target for lawsuits uh
because it's like oh dave ramsey bumped
into my car
you know so it's easier than winning the
lottery
who needed a job so um anyway but you're
not gonna quite be that way with one
rental property of course we're going to
tell you to pay cash for the rental
property or not buy it and don't do
things that don't make economic sense
only for tax reasons
okay and if you get tired of paying
taxes and mad about paying taxes like i
have and like you are
you can go that way
and i have found myself tempted to enter
into things that really don't make any
sense except the fact that they are a
huge tax write-off
and so i i don't do i would rather just
give it a charity and then you can write
it off
you know then i would go lose it and do
something bogus that gets me in a bind
later
in order to get a write-off so as long
as you're paying cash for the rental um
yeah throw it in an llc for risk
management doesn't change taxes same
depreciation schedule either way it's
all passed through on an llc it still
lands on your personal return doesn't
change a stinking thing as far as that
goes but yeah it's okay to start talking
about doing that and it is one of the
benefits of owning some real estate and
i'd talk with a tax pro if you don't
have one already you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com but working with one
of those elps they can look at your
whole situation and go oh here's a spot
you missed here's a spot we can save you
on taxes here's how to lower your
taxable income so that could help if
you're not already working with a pro
yeah and this idea that the rich don't
pay taxes
um
is 98 hogwash
i pay so much in taxes i can't breathe
i pay more in taxes
in a year than i made in the first 10
years of my working life wow i mean so
the idea that rich don't pay taxes
absolutely and i'm really good at this
stuff so it's just asinine that you know
well warren buffett's secretary pays at
a higher rate than he does yeah he lives
off capital gains which is a 15 rate
but it's 15 of a billion
and he's not he the only thing he has
are investments he has no earned income
only investments
so at a higher rate yes but his
secretary doesn't have a billion dollars
that she's living off of
and so she's paying ordinary income so
that's just a bogus argument too well
that's not fair that's absolutely fair
it's the tax code
sorry boys and girls still
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
entree leadership podcast the fine print
podcast and many other things around
ramsey is my co-host as we answer your
questions we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create real high
quality relationships it's your life and
it's right here on the radio ray is with
us ray is in cincinnati hi ray welcome
to the show
thanks uh thanks for taking my call guys
sure what's up my question is that
i'm looking for the best way to purchase
a family farm from a trust uh
my in-law offered to sell us the farm at
about half its value because he just
no longer can really maintain it he
wants to make sure he can uh i'd like to
see something done with it why you have
the ability to make the decisions uh why
he's got his health
i said it's already in a family trust
where my wife and four kids make up half
the trustees and it's like a dream
opportunity but we have about 90 000
left on our current mortgage and we're
hoping that in about two and a half
years we were going to be completely
debt free
but it's a dream for us to have the farm
so we didn't know if any ideas how to uh
make this happen any
special transfers or anything we can do
just trying to come up with a way to
make this happen okay who owns
who has the beneficial interest in the
trust who's the owner of the farm today
not your wife just this one-in-law
yes
okay so this one person is going to be
the only benefit
correct okay and what are they selling
it to you for what is the dollar amount
uh 300 000 it will be about half the
actual value
what is your i heard that part earlier
what is your house worth
i would say probably 400 000.
can you not live on the farm
uh well uh sorry i left that part out
they would love to stay they want to
stay on the farm until they pass
and no the farm house is not big enough
to hold our family
they live in the farmhouse now
correct
how many acres is the farm
roughly 90 acres would you farm it
well it's cash lease right now and that
farm income covers the taxes and
insurance and i would continue to do
that and then have some recreational
property there also
so when the person passes what will
happen to the farmhouse will you live in
it
uh at that point we don't know if it
would be uh you know would you build on
another portion of the farm
i don't believe so
i'm confused right this doesn't even
make sense you're saying this is your
dream but it also has no feasibility for
your family to live there
well it's uh just the location the
recreation the uh
owning the dirt is the dream not living
on it
correct okay
all right
um
well
here's what i think about doing all
right
i think about carving out one acre
around the house that the person who
wants to live in give them a life estate
to that house and one acre not to the
entire property
okay i would sell your house
and move into a rental and buy this
property
now you own it
okay then you've got two options one is
start saving like crazy for a good
strong down payment on a house
or
uh start talking about building on this
property and getting a construction loan
to do that
how far is it from your work
uh 30 miles how far are you from your
work now
25
no no no okay that's a break even
so i'm gonna challenge you to find a
corner of the property not right square
in the middle of the stinking thing and
look for a building site
all right okay so really then you're
you're gonna you're you're only going to
be in debt what it takes to build a
house
because you're going to pay cash for the
property when you sell your property
yes
okay how old is the people living in the
farmhouse
late 70s
do you want to rent until they leave
no okay probably not okay
so what i'm what i'm saying is okay how
big
here's your trade-off okay i always look
at things that are
trade-off in like one hand two hands
right the the old tipping of the scales
kind of a thing if you visualize the
scales of justice a little bit okay
you want to own this how bad do you want
to own it how much inconvenience are you
willing to go to to get to own it and do
it in a wise way paying cash for it from
the sale of your property sounds okay
that leaves you homeless however and
we've got to figure out a place for you
to park right
yes and so the trade-off is do you go
into debt to build you a house and put
it on a 15-year fixed or less and build
you a pretty nice property equal to the
one you've got now in the corner of the
farm somewhere leaving the rest of it
open for farming and recreation uh you
maybe turn the little uh
little farmhouse into a rental when the
people pass the uncle passes or whatever
um or you just go rent and start piling
up some cash and reassess your options
but now your dream is so are you willing
to on the negative side to rent or be
inconvenienced in order to live this
dream or you want your cake and eat it
too if you want your cake and eat it too
you're going to break yourself you don't
have enough money
yeah the thing is that
when they pass my wife and the kids
become 50 owners in it at that point
anyway
but then i think things get messy and
that's what i tend to worry about i
agree go ahead and close on it i'd sell
the one you live in i'd do the deal okay
you can buy a 600 000 property for 300
000 and basically they're advancing you
her half
is what they're doing they're not really
discounting it they're just advancing
you her half
right
and then and okay but you own the dirt
and then i'm gonna figure out some way
to live on that dirt if i'm you
and how desperate do you want to be on
that i mean
people have done some crazy things that
i wouldn't do that have called this show
like roll a
roll a uh
uh a trailer you know a 5000 trailer up
on there and park it or something i'm
not living in that but because i'm a
snob
but um
but you know you you figure out what
you're coming out with 400 000 house so
i'm not making that as a viable
suggestion okay
but what would ramsey's do uh i like
dirt you know
i got a 250 acre farm just over the hill
over here is one of my favorite places
on the planet
and so i'm i believe in owning some dirt
to keep the planet held together we
don't want it to come apart or anything
so
and and i like this it's in the family
you get you got you you like it it's in
your wife's family it's pretty cool i
think it's got a cool vibe on the thing
but don't go over there and go 300 000
in debt keep your 400 000 house and then
try to figure out why you're broke
because we will all know multiple
mortgages because you had this dream
yeah we will all know why you're broke
because you did stupid butt stuff
because you got all caught up in the
dream of this thing and thought it was
all just going to work out it ain't
going to work out you got to make it
work out dude you got to force it
through the mold
and uh that means you put stuff on the
other side of the scales the
inconvenient bad stuff living in a
rental building
waiting
something uncomfortable in order to make
this happen today and keep the messiness
of family out of it later this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org
budget we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
george do you realize we're gonna get to
do a live event in about a week not
virtual not virtual real people it's
like humans
it's virtual means sort of kinda yeah
we're not sort of kind of doing it we're
really freaking doing it game on human
beings and it's gonna be about 2 000 of
us there in las vegas will be there may
the 5th that is next thursday for most
of you and we are looking forward to
being there we're going to be doing one
of our
building wealth live events we're doing
them all over the nation this spring and
fall rachel cruz george campbell and i
and we're adding dr john delonie and
king coleman that's nice into the mix
and i'll be discussing things that are
going on in america right now
things that are people are talking about
and how do you really build wealth in
this current environment in this current
situation
las vegas is next week may 5th two weeks
later orlando on may the 19th
and that's followed by the entree
leadership summit the following week
there in orlando we'll be down there for
four days doing that that's going to be
about 3 000 folks uh small business
leaders from all over america a lot of
fun and then in the fall we will be
doing sacramento november the 1st
minneapolis november the 10th san
antonio november the 15th and we'll be
adding one more city very soon the
mystery will be unv failed i heard today
the contract is coming in i didn't even
know so this is news time to get the
venues under contract these days before
we can actually start talking about them
because
well people are just weird plans change
so there you go yeah
yeah on top of that smart conference
october 22nd in dallas that's right so
we've got a whole bunch of events all
over the place george we're gonna get
some work out of you that's what i'm
gonna get some miles too so i'm saying
crack the whip tickets are 25 each for
these building wealth live events a four
pack however you can get bring up you
know one of you couples bring another
couple with you that are friends y'all
make a great night of it you're going to
be entertained you're going to leave
inspired you're going to know what to do
to build wealth you're not going to be
under any illusions of any get rich
quick stuff or anything like that 60
dollars for a four pack that's only 15
bucks a piece you can't buy a pizza for
that so come out
we would love to have you again
vegas there's a few tickets left for
next week if you want to come orlando
just a couple you better get them quick
no may they're just about sold out for
here in may may 5th may 19th and uh the
ones for next fall are already over half
sold out wow and so don't wait around
i'm gonna get out i wish i'd gotten my
ticket really they're not that expensive
go get em my goodness gracious ramsay
solutions.com events is the place to go
that's exactly right thanks for that
reminder blinds.com is our question of
the day find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
free samples
free shipping
new promos all the time you save money
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal it's magic today's question
comes from davin in florida i'm a 45
year old single dad who has been
financially irresponsible for most of my
life
two years ago i became a full-time
firefighter with great benefits now i
have a deferred compensation plan saved
religiously towards my son's prepaid
college expenses and i'm putting 120
dollars a month into an index fund my
monthly expenses are my mortgage living
expenses 600 child support and a 200
chapter 13 bankruptcy payment i'm
hesitant about stopping my current
investments and my son's prepaid college
to pay off the 10 000 of chapter 13 debt
only because i've started so late in the
game i have no other debt should i
continue on the course i'm on or should
i stop all retirement investments and
put it towards the bankruptcy debt
what an interesting predicament he's
found himself in well i don't see this
any different than a different type of
debt i'm putting this in the debt
snowball i'm pausing all investments and
i'm going gangbusters to get rid of this
debt really fast yeah yeah
davin or devon however you pronounce it
the
truth is when you get the debts paid off
and you're out from under the chapter 13
bankruptcy
that's going to put your
financial irresponsibility and the shame
associated with it in the rear view
mirror
today
you get a monthly reminder
it's like i have to write i was a i used
to be stupid check
every month
you don't want to keep doing that you
want that in your rear view mirror
where
grace belongs
and look out the windshield towards a
beautiful bright future
what little
ground you lose by stopping temporarily
you're investing while you clear up the
debt you will be able to make up very
quickly
um and i will tell you that some of the
most successful people following our
plans
are first responders
uh firemen in most areas the way their
schedules are put together have
a an unbelievably
fabulous opportunity for side hustle
and a lot of them make more on their
side hustles than they do or as much as
they do being a firefighter
and um
so i know a bunch of them that build
decks and paint houses and do all kinds
of stuff got great side businesses
in their off days because you're you
know you're off half the time
uh and then when you're on you're on
completely so
uh you did say you're single dad so i
don't know what that entails here in
terms of being able to do the side
hustle but
all of that to say there's something
spiritually emotionally psychologically
uh
significant about putting that
bankruptcy in your rear view mirror plus
you're getting out of debt
so let's let's yeah georgia's exactly
that'll increase your cash flow on top
of that on top of the spirit part
mathematically you'll be able to do all
your stuff triple the money to invest
instead of 100 bucks and by the way i
wouldn't do prepaid college ever
i'd do a 529 in good mutual funds
uh you don't want to pre-pay a college
because you might not go there
and you might not go in that state and i
don't know how they've got it set up and
when you prepay something your rate of
return
on what you have prepaid is the
inflation rate of the item
college has traditionally been a seven
percent seven point two percent over the
last 50 years is the inflation rate on
tuition
and so you're making seven percent on
your money instead of 10 or 12 a good
mutual fund
and so you should be in a 529 good
mutual funds not in a prepaid college
anyway
and on top of that some of the states
that you people are paying into your
prepaid on they are awful with money
like illinois
illinois yeah but um
yeah horrible horrible financial
condition and i don't really want to
park my money with this institution that
is completely out of control
so no don't do that
good question shelby's in fort worth
texas hi shelby welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey so i just got an opportunity to
have a company car
and so now i'm wondering what to do with
my personal car i've got about thirty
four thousand working student loans and
some kind of unemployment
but
can you drive the company car for
personal use
yes i can
why would you keep the other car then
sell it
my concern is um if the company car has
to go in for any type of like longer
maintenance i i mean i drive the car
throughout
you know the city to different jobs and
homes and so if i don't have a car to
drive personally the company
tells you to put their car in for
maintenance they don't give you a
replacement
that is a good question i don't know i
just got it that would be normal by the
way and how often is this going in for
maintenance
well i mean i just got it so it's a
little older
over a hundred thousand miles so it may
be a little more frequent um
but
the company gave you a company car with
a hundred thousand miles on it
i'm in home health so it backs up easily
wow
so you're putting a lot of miles on a
car
yes okay and my commute in right now is
really long
it's about an hour commute but that'll
be decreasing in the summer okay i'd
sell it for top dollar your current car
and use that thing okay how big is your
company
um you are pretty big over the state
i'm sorry
they're pretty big all over the state
yeah okay because they just it's they
cheaped out on the car and i was just
curious why
oh i mean i don't i don't know it was it
was not supposed to be a permanent thing
i was just supposed to have it for a
couple months and then it kind of turned
into a long-term thing so i mean i don't
know how long they typically keep their
cars it could be at the end of a cycle
okay all right and
yeah i would get rid of it you don't
have any reason to pay pills on a car
sitting in your driveway you can get you
if all the whole deal falls apart for
whatever reason go get you another car
if the car goes in for extended
maintenance rent a car for a short
period of time all of that will be
cheaper than owning a car that's sitting
in your driveway paying tax and
insurance and
in general the thing's going down in
value it hasn't lately but in general it
is so yeah i'm getting rid of it
thanks for the call
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage drc and alan are
with us hey guys how are you hi hi dave
hi we're excited to meet you both you
too where do you guys live
we're in st augustine florida oh
beautiful area very cool welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
306 thousand
586 dollars and 66 cents
might be the nerd love it
might be it might be yeah and how long
did this take this took 42 months
okay and your range of income during
that time we started at 194 000 and went
up to 247 000. wow very cool what do
y'all do for a living i'm a pharmacist
and i'm a painting contractor very good
good okay was what kind of debt was this
was this the house
no
no no it's from a it was from a failed
business
from a failed business yeah okay tell us
the story what happened yes so actually
this is the second time we've gone
through um your baby steps so we had
completely paid off everything including
the house in 2017
and we apparently
did not learn our lesson hard enough
we thought a business was different so
we ended up getting some business loans
and and uh doing a business that that
ended up failing in about a year and a
half which is when you find out that
business is not different yes this is
not different and you need to listen to
your uncle dave
debt
is debt his debt is debt yes so what
kind of business was it yes it was a
hormone weight loss business okay and
what happened what caused it to fail
well we had it was a brick and mortar so
i would first advise nobody to do brick
and mortar if you can at all help it
and to um like we really had a marketing
um issue so lots of expense and then it
was hard getting people in the door so
okay not enough customers not enough
customers yes so do you still have a
paid for house
um no so this is all the business debt
that we we paid off so we still have the
house left but we are keeping our
expenses very very low so it's very very
manageable we should be able to have
that page
right now the house is the only debt
that we have right okay and so what was
this like sba loans or
um
no we had taken like the equity from a
house that we had paid off and used a
lot of that and then on top of that we
were we were trying to support the
marketing so we were getting a bunch of
different um loans and credit cards for
that so okay yeah cool
so the thing crashes you close it up
and then you go okay now i got to clean
this up yes yes and that was 42 months
ago yes yes wow so we were that's a hard
debt to pay off emotionally
yeah i mean it's one thing to go buy
something stupid at the store and then
have that on a credit card but the the
failed business breaks your heart yes
and you know it just makes you beat
yourself up and now i got to pay
payments on it oh my gosh it's like a
it's like paying alimony it's awful it's
on the old marriage you know it's like
ugh absolutely it was like one of the
darkest times of life that i've ever
been through and uh you know i just
was so
grateful that you know we were able to
do it together and walk through it
together and and kind of make progress
forward and
and um just just grateful to be out of
that dark place
well you guys you guys did a lot of
hustling and grinding okay and so the
business closed um were one of you
already
you're already a pharmacist i'm sure
okay and were you already doing painting
yes okay so you just took those and made
them the full-time gig and beefed it up
and went on yes okay all right and then
just roll up your sleeves you get after
it yes yes yes just we had a huge xl
sheet of all the little things and just
took them one by one through the
snowball like i give your debt snowball
app a workout
throw in snowballs what is there for
that's awesome yeah so what was the
hardest part for you guys i mean 42
months is a long time and that's a whole
big pile of debt
what was the hardest part i think just
the emotional part of it
you know a lot of a lot of self-doubt
and
you know pain yeah sleep sleepless
nights and just wondering if you know
can we can we really do this like can we
get through it and um
yeah i mean
god god willing we we were and we had we
had a lot of support
yeah
well
as dark as it is too as you start
approaching the light at the end of it
it gets really really super exciting
cause it's like i'm just about done with
this crap right i mean i remember this i
remember this exact set of emotions yeah
every every two weeks our our daughter
would help us with the little chart that
we had going so she'd take out her
little pink highlighter and help us
along so it was it was so satisfying as
you see the depth snowball grow and you
see you're making these like huge chunks
on your debt you know which you never
thought were possible and so now we're
seeing the glimmer you know on the
horizon and we see how we can flip it
and then you know that's going to be
start to be our savings and and really
make some major progress here in the
next couple years
most of us that have closed a small
business though experienced a certain
amount if not a lot of shame
for the goof up that is associated with
it and the further you got down the debt
snowball the more that was in your
rearview mirror the thing i experienced
was i was more and more and more free of
not just the debt and the the arithmetic
but that shame was further back there
it's like oh that's back there that's
back there i'm not that guy anymore i
learned it i got it it's back there last
little bit i gotta sweep up this one
more corner and we're done yes but what
was hard was even preparing for today we
were putting together our little like
placard of saying how much we paid off
and and just looking at the number i
mean i know
you know i know the number because i'm
the nerd but just looking at the number
on the placard of how much we paid off
is like oh it just you know hits you in
the gut and it's done but it's done it's
just done the stun is finished we're
here this is our celebration again never
again again
for anything for anything yeah you you
never again yeah it's this lesson is now
seared that was a hot stove with a lot
of zeros at the end of it yes yes wow
well you guys are inspiring and you said
you had a lot of support who are your
biggest cheerleaders oh so so many
support so many people like really
really helped us we um
we
did go through financial peace
university
a couple different times and are so glad
for all of the sets of families that
that went through that with us we
actually um
co-led it and we co-led it at numa life
church so just want to give a shout out
to our church and also to our ramsay
preferred coach heather seymour who has
been along for for the ride with us she
really helped us especially with the
business finances
and getting that dialed in and the debt
there so we can the point she actually
comes up here and does the debt free
screen with you yes that's ultimate
support right there
absolutely and i i also want to thank
a close friend of mine chris larson for
all the support he gave me yeah yeah
yeah you got to have friends in your
corner when you're going through this
it's a big deal
i mean it's a big deal what you all been
through is is incredible i'm proud of
you for walking through it because it's
a tough tough slog uh getting out of
debt's one thing getting out of this
kind of debt in this situation with all
the emotions and things around it it's
um it's a big deal very well done very
very very well done what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
now you've been through for the fpu a
couple times and now you did the hard
stuff what do you tell them
well
i was going to say the the biggest thing
that i learned from going through this
is from
my wife and i getting on the same page
and um you know just coming to an
agreement with every decision that we
made
and you know we haven't had enough even
going through all of this we haven't had
a fight
over finances since 2009. wow that's a
big deal yeah because all along together
we made the financial decisions like it
had to be like two thumbs up or we
weren't doing it so we were in it
together and we fought through it
together and you know having your steps
to really have a framework of like okay
this is how we're gonna do it we're
gonna agree on this framework and we're
going to solution and move forward
love it well done we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter you're on your way
i love it and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody in your fpu group or somebody
you want to stir up a ruckus with i love
it and have to say hello to genevieve
and campbell our kids that are at home
very cool
all right drc in allen st augustine
florida 307 000 paid off in 42 months
making 199 to 247. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
i felt that one deep down yeah wow real
real stuff going on there never gets old
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
jeanette is in savannah georgia hi
jeanette how are you
hi i'm good thank you so much for taking
my call sure what's up
so
my husband and i i'm kind of caught
between my husband and my grandmother
and i love them both so much and i want
to love them well i'm hoping you can
give me some advice
we've been married for about a year
we're debt-free except for our mortgage
our household income is about 90 000 a
year we both work a billion dollars
overtime
and i've been financially supporting my
grandparents since before we got married
and we agreed that i continue to do that
for them because they're on a very fixed
income
and that comes out to about 700 a month
that i hope to pay their rent
when my grandfather passed away very
suddenly in june of last year
her income of course took a big hit
because now there's just her social
security the plan was that when the
lease was up in july
that she would move in with us to save
money and she's in the process of
selling
a piece of commercial property that's
her only asset
and we're going to use that money to buy
her a permanent house that she can live
in with no payment
well she told me yesterday that she's
just not emotionally ready to move it
hurts too much even for her to look at
my grandfather's things much less
pack them up and come stay with us with
nothing in her hand but a suitcase
and she wants me to extend the lease for
her
my husband wants what's best for all of
us
financially especially because we're
expecting our first baby in july as well
and he's pretty adamant that giving
money to a rental company is
a waste when she can live with us or you
know just temporarily
and i'm i'm kind of he's correct 100
percent mathematically
but then i've also got the emotional
side of the equation from her and i'm
desperately looking for a third option
do you think that i should
extend the lease for her or try to
convince her to stay with us or maybe
just extend the lease for a few months
to give the property time to sell
i just
just don't know what would be the wise
decision here
i'm sorry that's a hard place to be
and it is it sure is and how supportive
and hard-working
uh she's in her mid-seventies
how long has she lived in this rental
about two years i used to live she used
to live there with me before i got
married and moved out and they continued
to live there after i got married
does she attend a local church
she does she is very active in her in
her local church and she has friends to
support her and everything but it's
you know they they were married for
you know over 30 years i can't imagine
what she's going through and my heart's
broken for her but at the same time
i want all of us to be okay
well
um
i'm it's just sad
uh the thing is this her staying in this
house for a few more months is not going
to mean her heart is not broken
right her 30-year best friend is gone
her heart's just broken
and she's confusing that
that this house location
which isn't a human thing by the way
there's nothing wrong she's not doing
anything wrong but um
the truth is is that um
she's gonna have she's going to deal
with the grief of this situation in a
location and a rental house she's been
in for two years
doesn't enter into the emotional part of
it it's just she's
she's just wishing that this wasn't the
story
and i can pretend i can put my hands
over my ears and go la la la la la this
story is not happening if i can just
stay in this house
and so it's it's kind of a form of
denial if you will i think
do you think i'm wrong
you know i i think you're right i think
she's having a really hard time
i would have a little more i would i
would i would agree with her a little
bit more if she'd lived in this house
for 30 years
you know
but it's been there two years
and so to associate that with him being
gone
is not as logical does that is that a
lot do you see what i'm saying
yeah and i i get that she's hurting i i
i'm not i don't want to diminish that
and i don't think
the way you've presented this that your
husband is diminishing that
i think he's just going look
we've all got to deal with this and it's
just there's no good
ending to this story because pop you
know grandpa's just gone i mean and he's
just gone to heaven and so it you know
it's just gonna hurt
whatever we do is gonna hurt
and so um
and how long ago did he pass again
um almost a year in june last year
it feels like on top of the you know on
top of the emotions he's looking at the
facts going well this is she's broke and
so without you she doesn't have any
options and so at that point i go okay
she lives with us for a little bit and
then we sell this commercial property
she processes through the grief as much
as she can and maybe you can give her
some tools to do that but either way
she's gonna have to get out of this
thing because you can't fund her life
forever
you know i
i i think that you're on you know
you've got a good plan overall um
and um
while i my heart breaks for your your
grandma i think your husband's probably
right not from a math standpoint but
even from just loving your grandmother
well standpoint because she just needs
some people to grieve with and you being
there for and a new baby in the house
and all that kind of stuff it's it's a
that's a good place for her to kind of
heal and spend time with
you know and living in this rental house
with the the past all around her just
isolated is not that doesn't facilitate
her
going through the hurt and the pain of
this it doesn't facilitate her going
through the grieving process so i
probably the reason i ask about the
church is if she respects her pastor
i'd probably you know the two of you sit
are you and your husband and grandma sit
down with pastor
and let pastor you know kind of
be the spiritual guide and maybe he even
takes some of the lumps instead of your
husband taking them because maybe he
suggests
that she go ahead and get out of there
and get moved
because i think that's what's best for
her
not
you know it also happens to be what's
best for y'all but i think it's what's
best for her
because her reasoning for staying there
is to say i'm going to pretend like this
didn't happen i want to live in the past
a little while longer that's going to
make me not hurt and not walk through
the process of the grief here and i want
her to
to
dr dalonio he says grief demands a
witness and so when he's got she's got
you and your husband and the new baby
and she's right there and
and um
you know she's not lonely she's not
sitting there in that rental house by
herself watching some stupid television
thing you know
you know what i'm saying i think it's
just best for her
okay
and i i knew that i know that you're
right i know that he's right it's just
it's so hard for me to watch her cry you
know so
well my point is she's really not crying
about a rental house
yeah she's really crying because
grandpa's gone
yeah and that's okay she's supposed to
cry
i mean i've been married 40 years
um we plan on me dying before sharon
because i won't do well without her
[Laughter]
it's a it's part of the estate plan i
pre to cease her i mean it's just it's
the way we've arranged it
as long as there's no more details about
how that's gonna go then it gets scary
but sharing planning don't ask about
sharon's plans okay but yeah
well jeanette i'd love to send you a
copy of john dolone's new book on your
past change your future i'm hoping it
gives you some tools maybe some tools
for grandma maybe you guys can go
through it together i don't know what
that looks like for you but we'll have
kelly pick up and send you guys a copy
because i think that can give her some
tools some resources to process through
this very very difficult thing yeah i i
do think the pastor with his arm around
her
and you and your husband sitting there
and y'all praying and her crying
through this decision
is probably gonna help her
and i don't want the end of this story
to be your husband ends up being the bad
guy to grandma or to you either one
because he's not
and uh he you did not describe him as
belligerent or greedy or this is not
about money
uh and then just thinking it through it
with you here on the air it really does
appear to us that it's really what's
best for her emotionally
psychologically oh and the finances also
happen to line up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create real
and amazing relationships george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour this is a baby steps
millionaire theme hour thank you for
joining us america we're so glad you're
here
we're going to be talking with real
millionaires this year people who really
are millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion we're
asking how you really did it
what really happened
now a millionaire is not someone that
makes a million dollars a year george a
millionaire someone with a million
dollar net worth what you
own minus what you owe it's a simple
formula
equals a million dollars or more than
your millionaire
that is your net worth
there's not multiple definitions well
he's a net worth millionaire that's
redundant
there's only one type of millionaire and
that is a net worth millionaire someone
who earns an income of a million dollars
or more is not a millionaire by any
definition this is an accounting term it
is a financial planning term it is not
a societal commentary it is not a moral
construct and so you don't get to
freaking change it it's just this is
what a millionaire is and this is the
only way you get to be a millionaire you
have a million what you own minus what
you owe is in excess of a million
dollars doesn't matter if it creates an
income or not you can have a family farm
that just sits and it's just dirt and
it's worth two million dollars and
that's all you have then you're worth
two million dollars because you can sell
it for two million dollars
hypothetically so there you go so
anybody that has a million dollars we
want to talk to you this hour because we
want to find out what you did and how
you did it did you win the lottery did
you inherit the money uh are you a
famous rock star
uh did you um i don't know some other
bizarre thing that people believe that
doesn't ever really happen these are
percentage-wise never occur but if
you're any of those that's wonderful
we'd love to talk to you however you got
your million we want to hear your story
to tell people how they can do it open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're talking with
real millionaires mike's gonna start us
off in california mike what's your net
worth
dave thank you for having me today um
2.6 million oh very good okay cool and
um very good and so break that down for
me what's the mix on it
the mix is uh 1.4
and that's a combination about um 80
401k and 20 roth okay so 1.4 in
retirement all right and the other uh
1.2
is the
is my home
your your home is worth 1.2
exactly i'll get that off um
two weeks ago oh good for you very good
yeah okay how old are you thanks thanks
thanks to you dave 60.
60. well i didn't pay it you did way to
go how much of the uh uh 2.6 million
that you have did you inherit
uh zero zero okay cool
and uh what was your best year household
income since you've been working and
you're worst your household incomes that
you've been working
uh 50 to
over um 200k cool what you do for a
living
both my wife and i are in sales she's in
food distribution and i'm in i.t cool
you got a four-year degree
um
high school yes
a high school degree okay cool do you
remember your gpa
3.3 and my wife was through 3.8 okay
cool good good she's a she's a smart one
no i got you yeah i understand she
picked you yeah so
[Laughter]
all right so uh
do you use an investment professional or
did you do all this yourself
oh yeah we started to uh of course you
know through our whole venture through
um at pu and
and yeah once once we went through all
that dave yes we got our
financial advisor and set up our trust
and everything so
we've we followed your plan awesome mike
i'm curious was this a goal of yours or
did it just kind of happen
right now i've been holding a big date
fan i've been a big dave fan for about
15 years i've been doing davish
so would you say this is a 15-year
journey that you've kind of set out on
intentionally well for myself and until
my wife you know jumped on board um
you know about seven years ago and
we and and
it's it helps it helps the marriage it
helps communication and
we just um we just went after it and we
focus on the house and and we did it wow
very good good for you man i'm proud of
you how's it feel
awesome i mean it's it's freedom
and yeah so we're thinking what are we
gonna do now
and
it's it's like it's exciting to see
where we're gonna move forward yes yeah
wow good for you
and i'm gonna you know dave i want to
give a shout out to my wife i love her
she's she's on the road she wanted to be
here um we're just big fans and i just
wanted to tell her i love her wow that's
very cool that's the way it works man
well done rockstar okay now
you're 60 years old you have a 2.6
million dollar net worth you make 200
000 a year household income you live in
california
if someone's out there listening this 22
can they still do what you did
uh for sure
i think my my son is a good example you
know with
if he knows knows the value of a dollar
and if you want to um buy something you
save for it and you buy it
um
it drives used cars
and image is overrated
um
yeah just live your life who cares about
whatever what anybody else thinks
very well done hey brother we're proud
of you congratulations another baby
steps millionaire out there after the
name that's what we named the book after
was these guys just like mike and his
wife how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
see the misnomer george is that everyone
inherited their wealth
that they don't deserve it that's the
biggest lie that's the biggest lie well
it also infers that if you don't have a
rich uncle you're screwed
and what mike is saying is you're not
you can do this
you can get out you can get out of debt
you can live on lesson you make you
don't worry about image and you put
money away and ta-da
but it's easier to get mad at rich
people dave than it is to do the work
that's the truth
well
it is but it's not as effective
and it doesn't get you what you want to
get and if you believe a lie you will
then function in that lie and
that's how we started doing this theme
hour is uh and then we ended up doing
the largest study of millionaires that
has ever been done in north america over
10 167 of them studied and we asked them
in great detail what their
um
you know what their process was who they
are we found that 79 inherited precisely
zero
that five percent inherited a very small
amount like five thousand dollars from
the grandmother or something like that
and another five percent inherited good
money big money like a hundred thousand
bucks or something but after they were
already millionaires
and so that five plus five plus 79
gives you the number of 89
percent of america's millionaires are
not
that because of inheritance
it's a big deal george yeah it's because
of intentionality consistency over time
94 said they live on less than they make
it's that simple wow if you just do that
you will be wealthy
what a concept well maybe they should
run for congress
i don't think they'll make it through
live on less than you make
a concept congress can't grasp
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking to sell your house
right now it can be overwhelming but you
don't have to sell your home alone you
need an endorsed local provider by your
side our elps are ramsey trusted that
means they're highly vetted they're top
tier real estate agents that my team and
i trust they're pros who are excited to
serve you and help you sell your home at
the right price
if you're ready to get a home sold to
get with a ramsey trusted elp in your
corner and it's free to connect of
course just go to ramseysolutions.com
agent you can find one near you ramsey
solutions.com
agent it's a baby steps millionaires
theme hour my latest number one
bestselling book baby steps millionaires
how ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can
too
maggie is with us in st louis hey maggie
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave how
are you better than i deserve what's
your net worth
uh my husband and i our net worth is 1.2
million okay give me a little breakdown
on that how much retirement how much
house and so on
we have about
575 000 in rocks uh almost a hundred
thousand in traditional so about six to
seven hundred thousand and retirement we
have 425 thousand equity on our house
about fifty thousand sitting in a
savings account and college
savings and other assets are about 40
000. cool how old are you guys
we i am 39 our goal was to be
millionaires by the time we were 40 and
i met that at the end of my 37th year so
you made it amazing we made it i love it
how much of this 1.2 million did you
guys inherit
you know we did not inherit any of it in
fact when we found you in 2007 we are
575 000 in debt
whoa
yeah this is a turnaround i talked to
you i talked to you in 2007 when we
first started i called into the show was
it nice to you
no
you ended this my call was oh what a
mess
and it wasn't a mess
it's been known to happen and here you
are two million dollars later it's 575
negative to 1.2 positive i love it
so what is your range of income in your
working life your best year ever in your
worst year ever
our worst year was about a hundred
thousand together our best which only
happened one year was 325.
what do you guys do what's your career
we are both pharmacists ah very good
okay explains the debt
yes it does 300 000 in debt i got it
okay
and so uh your degree is obviously in
pharmacy what was your gpa
mine was pretty high i was uh 3.9
my husband was about a 2.8 oh
just like that
he's yep yep
so they they really don't care about
that once you get into the real world
they care about your ability to work and
your hard work did you count the pills
in that bottle correctly that's all they
care about
yeah
oh my gosh incredible very well done
yeah love it yeah so what do you tell
people can they still do this
they absolutely can do this there is
hope
um even if the dave ramsey says that
your finances are a mess but there's no
that's the best part i mean you guys had
in over 15 years you had almost a 2
million dollar turnaround what do you
attribute that to obviously you guys had
a great income but you guys are really
intentional
um yeah we were i think in the beginning
before we had kids we were living about
20 of our income and tithing 10
and then putting 70 percent into
trying to get out of debt was mainly um
but a good communication
like i just think you know when we
started my husband wasn't super
interested in it the only reason he want
he went to a dave ramsey class was
because we were new to the area and he
wanted to meet people but after
after listening to one the first lesson
he was hooked
but just like good communication i think
was a thing in the ability to just
make it fun throughout the process and
have goals
and we definitely made a ton of mistakes
along the way
i'm telling you i'm proud of you guys
what you've done is very intense i mean
you're millionaires by the time you're
40 and you overcame a 575 000 debt hole
very impressive so on the opposite end
of the story the first time i talked to
you i said it what a mess now i'm saying
what a champion um i like that what an
amazing what an amazing couple of people
very well done that's incredible very
well inspiring all right nick is with us
in connecticut hi nick uh what's your
net worth
hi dave my net worth is 1.5 million cool
very good uh how old are you
uh 33. oh wow young millionaire give me
a little breakdown on that uh 1.5
between retirement house and whatever
else it's in
okay uh 1.5 uh yeah sorry 150 000 home
equity
50 000 in other equity
one uh 150 000 in a an ir traditional
ira and my proud claim of
1.15 million in a roth ira
wow big roth you've been kicking it at
33 to get it to that point very good so
how much of this money did you inherit
not a dime zero
and what's your best working year and
your worst working year
since you've been well
yeah with my wife it's about 75k and uh
lowest and highest 120. okay cool what
do y'all do what do you do for a living
uh i'm between jobs i'm looking to get
into banking and investing and my wife
manages a nit team cool you got a
four-year degree
i do not okay does she
yes in in what
uh psychology okay cool very good all
right and uh
good good for you
okay so how do you do this by 33 years
old dude you loaded this thing up this
is impressive
uh honestly i got a bit lucky like i
said i've been uh my passion's been
investing
um
i know i have to disclose that i was i
am a reformed i'm gonna self self called
degenerate
i got involved with wall street bets hit
gamestop really big got out and i am in
mutual funds and etfs now
so you cashed the chips off the table
before you took the hit
exactly so this all happened very
recently
yeah this was in january of 2021. so
what was your net worth before that
55k oh my goodness
that's
quite the jump from 55k net worth to 1.5
million
and uh you took some risks if you had
this time if you had not taken the chips
off the table you'd almost be back there
wouldn't you
something like that but yeah no i when
the time was right getting out getting
good and putting it somewhere safe yeah
your timing your timing is impeccable
very well done good for you man i'm
proud for you a needle in a haystack
kind of story i'm proud for you though
it's a good thing to i like talking to
somebody that did it that's good and uh
the trick because most people don't have
the uh
they get they get lured by the siren
song of the success and they stay in
and they end up riding the same horse
until it dies
uh instead of getting out at the top and
you were smart enough wise enough to get
out the top and realizing that this is
not a forever play
so well done
at least i guess that's what happened is
that what happened
yeah uh
january 28th uh 2021 will be the most
stressful day of my life
i had a a million dollar loss and
unrealized games and then the next day
we sold it at the top wow
amazing wow
hard to replicate wouldn't recommend it
to to our listeners but it's not a
method that works very often but it got
you got it done so that's what we we
take the calls from however you did it
and we want to hear the true story so
good for you man i'm proud of you open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so talking to some
young millionaires today a 60 a 39 a 33.
wow well everybody that's rich or crooks
greedy rich people greedy rich people
no
i hadn't talked to any of those today
none of these people stole their money
none of them did anything illegal wow
no drug deals here
just hard work not that we're aware of
not that they're willing to tell us not
that was admitted to here on the air
yeah and we haven't talked to anybody
who had a
number one best-selling record yeah i
said most of them hit millionaire status
at age 49 in our study and if you took
the average here i think you'd find
something similar
yeah the average isn't just 49 of those
three right very interesting we'll talk
to some more millionaires right here on
a baby steps millionaire female
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour here on the ramsey show we talk to
real millionaires and find out how they
really
did it not so what someone's political
opinion is
or people with uh
their expertise coming from twitter
uh which would by definition be an
oxymoron so expertise from twitter is an
oxygen was the keyword [ __ ] in that
sentence it could be okay yeah there's a
real key word george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five as we talk to
millionaires rob is in omaha nebraska
rob what is your net worth
hi dave hey george my network is 1.2
million cool give me a little breakdown
on that by category
sure
we have a paid for house 255 000
cash 170 000 emergency fund 32 000
22 000 hsa 129 000 in some other
equities
uh 540 000 in retirement
uh and then
you know the rest is in a 529. very good
how old are you
i am 35 my wife is 34. excellent how
much of this 1.2 million did you inherit
zero okay and what's your best working
year
of your working lifetime household
income and worst working year
this year is slated to be the best uh
our base will be somewhere around 3 30
potentially at the 372 uh depending on
how bonuses pay out early on when we got
married it was 45 000. cool what do
y'all do for a living i am an i.t
security and risk management and my wife
is in accounts payable and is also a
real estate agent wow you guys are
killing it this is great so what's your
degree in
i have a bachelor's in mis and computer
science and an mba and my wife has a
bachelor's in business administration
and entrepreneurship wow what's your gpa
when you're in school
i was a 3-8 both for undergrad and
graduate my wife was three eight okay
good cool
okay well done you did this quick man 35
years old proud of you so uh can this
still be done if you're 25 listening to
this
absolutely it can be done earlier if you
start earlier too that's what we kick
ourselves about the biggest mistake was
not not doing it earlier wow how old
were you guys when you started this
uh when we really
got focused uh you know stumbled across
the ramsey uh team it was our late 20s
probably 26 27 and then when we just got
focused and got to it so in under 10
years
and we're able to accomplish this that's
amazing because a lot of people think in
their minds well yeah i'll get there
when i'm 65 i don't want to wait that
long but it doesn't take that long when
you're intentional yeah the average is
17 years you guys did this really fast
but you have a way above average income
so you were killing it so that's pretty
cool well done man very very well done
all right what do you tell people the
secret to becoming a millionaires
you have to know your your why and you
have to set your sights on a goal uh
both my wife and i
want the ability to control time you
know to do what you want when you want
where you want it as long as
you have the ability to separate
yourself from the system and not have to
make a payment to another that gives you
the ability to spend your time to find
what gives you that true level of
happiness and no no stuff can offer that
a lot of wisdom there that's pretty
profound wow
separate yourself from the system i love
that stick it to the man
i love it absolutely that's very cool
very good hey man we're very proud of
you congratulations very well done rob
sean is next sean's in louisville
kentucky sean what's your net worth
i'm right at a million dollars dave look
at you
and uh how old are you
i'm 33 years old a bunch of young ones
today all right good okay i love it so
give me a little break down on your
million dollars how's that broken down
by category
yes i have a paid off house right at a
half a million dollars i own some other
real estate property at 200 000.
um have a roth ira at about 200 000
and the rest isn't in cash good for you
and what's your best year working income
worst your working income since you
started
well i i vary a lot on my salary i'm in
sales and so best year was right at half
a million dollars that was a few years
ago
and then uh but when i started in my
industry i was starting helped out so i
was making minimum wage right at about
eight dollars an hour and just worked my
way up in the industry and and now i i
lead a sales team okay what do you sell
uh so i sell itsaf software okay
excellent all right very cool
uh that's making a lot of sense what do
you have a degree
uh i actually have a degree in biblical
and theological studies and a master's
in pastoral counseling so i got into the
industry to pay my way through school
and next thing i knew i had
had kids
and
made a career out of it love it what was
your gpa when you're in school
uh 3.85 is what i averaged golly okay
good good
okay so you've made a lot of money and
that's part of the what has contributed
to this you've had some really good
years
what else do you
attribute this level of success at 33
years old to
well dave
during that time i've had a lot of hard
years and so a big portion of it was
just
always staying out of debt
especially early you know when i was
pulling in
20 30 000 a year
you know if a car breaks down it could
have been one thing that would have set
you back and it would have been very
hard to survive so just you know always
having that emergency fund
living within your means
but also being proactive with my savings
so i'm very much the type that
if i have to do something i tend not to
do it because i just get busy and so
within my savings i was having it
automatically pulled out i was maxing
out my 401ks and so i just didn't need
to think about my savings plans yeah
yeah was get after it was this instilled
in you from parents where did all this
come from this mindset
it very much was my dad he you know he
kind of taught me the power of compound
interest
at a young age and he would tell me you
know the math problems that if you save
starting young what it would be worth
when you were older and
so he talked that through with me and
also taught me the lessons that he
learned
you know with um with making different
financial decisions one of which was
never buying a new car so he always
bought a car with 50 000 miles on it
right now i'm driving a truck with 198
000 miles on it wow that's amazing
well done
well done i love it well congratulations
brother we're very very very proud of
you so you're the moral of the story for
you is it still can be done
it absolutely can and you know i also
had a i went unfortunately went through
a divorce which was the hardest time and
so i lost in the middle of that lost
half my assets
within that and you know just being out
of debt it was what made me survive it
just took that stress off of me yeah wow
and still come back at 33 with a million
dollar net worth pretty amazing
well well done sir thank you for sharing
your story this is uh this is how it's
done
so george we've been doing these uh
millionaire theme hours
baby steps millionaire theme hours for
several years now
the number of times that um
someone calls in and says that they are
a millionaire because they inherited it
and which by the way there's no shame in
that i do remember precisely one guy
calling and he's like yeah
i mean mom and dad followed your stuff
uh they had ten million dollars when
they died they left us each three
million dollars
and um
no shame in that yeah and he's like the
way i'm gonna honor their memory is i'm
gonna do the same stuff they did i'm
gonna stay out of debt and i'm gonna
invest steadily and so
uh hey we don't throw any shade on that
at all we'll go with it you know that's
that's a wonderful story that's a legacy
story yeah but the number of times that
happens is very low almost all of the
people have zero inheritance or very
close to zero inheritance such a small
inheritance that it didn't matter
you know sometimes they'll joke and say
oh my grandmother left me an old car you
know or something like that but
most of the time uh the thing they got
from their parents was work ethic
um
maybe they got from their parents an
example of what not to do yeah that can
be a strong why as well either way they
they did not have an inheritance and
they end up millionaires we're talking
to real millionaires this hour it's a
baby steps millionaires theme hour here
on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day luke 14 28
suppose one of you wants to build a
tower won't you sit down first and
estimate the cost to see if you have
enough money to complete it
stephen covey said make time for
planning wars are won
in the general's tent
whoo there you go
i like that it's a millionaire theme
hour a baby steps millionaire theme hour
here on the ramsey show george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
the lies that are out there about the
wealthy are this that they all inherited
their wealth 89 did not become
millionaires
according to actual research not
someone's political opinion
well the wealthy are all crooks
nope
there's a percentage of the wealthy that
are crooks and there's a percentage of
poor people that are crooks as a matter
of fact there's just a percentage of
people that are crooks
and it actually runs about the same
really when you really get down to it
uh you know when a rich person is a
crook it just
it's it's with more scale
it's easier to hate on yeah well and
it's you know but they're they're
actually crooks they just do i mean
burning made off they do it with scale
right more zeros on it yeah and uh so
it's it's more you know it's a bigger
flash when it happens and so
most millionaires most wealthy people
are famous entertainers
famous athletes
rock stars actors
no
less than one percent
of wealthy people are people of
notoriety
people of note that you would know their
name they're not household names
so there's wealthy people out there like
that they're you know they're the
and sometimes they're crazier than a
bean you know if they're in some of the
entertainment stuff that's out there and
sometimes they're regular folks if
they're in some of the entertainment
stuff that's out there but um the wealth
isn't what did it it's just that they
were crazy in a bean and they got some
money and so we noticed them
and uh they can do crazy on steroids
you've met some of those people and some
of them are broke man we have we met
some interesting ones
uh they're all wealthy people i can't be
wealthy because all wealthy people are
brilliant they're all the 4.0 nope
haven't talked to one today they got a
4.0
um
they're not dumb
they're not a 1.0
they didn't get a degree in beer pong
but uh
but they're usually around a three
somewhere three percent or a three
uh point something gpas what all of them
today have been anyway and that's about
right that's what we normally
occasionally run into a 4.0 but you
don't have to be you don't need to you
do have to be i mean smart
but you know versus dumb but but you
don't have to be brilliant
inordinately brilliant to build wealth
you just have to be smart enough to keep
doing your 401k and get your house paid
off and that's generally what causes
people to become millionaires right
there gabriel is with us in clarksville
tennessee gabriel what's your net worth
it's about 1.2 million good for you well
done
and uh give me a little breakdown on
that by category please
um
i have uh two iras two one for my wife
and one for me
uh how much is in this brokerage account
those um it's a little it's about two
220. okay 25. cool and then uh a
brokerage account and that's got about
uh 300 000 in it gotcha and then my
house is worth uh
uh 330 000
and then i have a
uh not a mutual fund uh um a money
market account that's got about 250 000
in it
and then the last category is i paid for
my kids college which came out to 165
000 and he is an investment now gotcha
okay very good
very good how old are you
i am 55. perfect okay cool how much of
this 1.2 million did you inherit none
zero all right and your best working
year and worst working year household
income
uh best working year was uh i retired
from the army but um uh it was 120k a
year and worse working here i guess when
i was a private you know making i guess
you know less than 10 grand a month okay
or less than a thousand dollars a month
right don't you okay
so your career was military thank you
for your service
you're welcome all right you have a
four-year degree
i do i have a master's as well okay
master's in what
mba oh good okay good and what was your
gpa
i think 3.7 on the masters and then my
bachelor's was like a 3.3
yeah people always get a little more
serious on the masters okay good good
for you man well done a little more
application of self yeah good okay so
you're 55 years old you're talking to a
young
private
that's 23
making no money
you can't be a millionaire
is he right if he says that
nope
what should he do
you should follow the baby steps and get
on a budget i know for me that that
budget thing was hard when we first
started doing this uh 14 years ago i
want to say
and um
and not that we were in a lot of debt
but we would just spend money like crazy
and we owned two houses with two
mortgages
and we moved and so now they became um
long long just long distance real estate
which worked out for me
uh but in 2008 with the housing
market crashing i got upset that the um
uh the ceos of uh banks were still
getting bonuses
uh for that and you know me and my wife
were like we got to get rid of these
mortgages instead of them getting them
the bonus one we get the bonus and then
i ran into a billboard that had your
face on it in uh greenville south
carolina i was teaching rotc at furman
university at the time yeah and i'm like
i gotta listen to this guy and you were
on tv back then
and um and we started the budget the
first one was very difficult
and now we come out pretty even you know
we still do a budget every month
and um and it took us we had a five-year
plan to pay the houses off
i got promoted and then i got deployed
which you know
in turn created more money coming in and
so that five-year plan turned into a
four-year plan
and um and haven't looked back ever
since and then you know we were we
readjusted um you know how much we were
investing because we were all over the
map you know we were investing we were
paying mortgages we were buying stuff we
shouldn't have bought
um you got focus
you got focused you were doing a lot of
different things and you went let's just
focus on this one path the baby steps
and it worked
and you you still do a budget because
that's how you stay a millionaire
yeah live on less than you make
yep that's awesome what kind of car do
you drive
i have a rav4 and a toyota camry what
years are they
the rav is a 2017 and the camry's 2016.
of course i bought them both used of
course there you go if you want to know
what a millionaire drives
it's probably more like that than it is
the sports car next to you when you're
driving unless you're driving next to
dave and then you can uh you you'll know
you're driving next to a millionaire
well done gabriel i'm proud of you man
and uh again thanks for your service
that's beautiful beautiful work
excellent excellent job the good stuff
so guys this is how it's done uh the
point of this hour is to give you real
facts that give you hope
because if you believe
that i can't be a millionaire because
everybody inherits their wealth then you
believe a lie
and we want to disperse that
if you believe i can't be a millionaire
because the only way to become wealthy
is to be crooked and steal
i want to disperse that because most of
the people we talk to are not crooks
matter of fact all of them we talk to
are not crooks
and uh you know if you believe you have
to get a 4.0 i want to disperse that i
want to dispense with these lies this
mythology because it steals your hope
and these people out here that are
spreading this crap are hope stealers
yeah
you just have to do what actual
millionaires do which is have integrity
or a card do something logical and
consistent over a period of time and
you'll get there it may not be tomorrow
but i mean looking at these facts you go
okay well 10 years from now i could have
a huge turnaround 15 years from now what
could life be like 20 years from now
where could we be so you've got to have
that long-term vision a lot of them
mentioned that vision they had for their
life whether it's a debt-free screen or
millionaire status you've got to have
that vision you've got to do a budget
you've got to live on less than you make
none of it's rocket science today they
were young 60 39 33 35 33 and 55. wow
yeah sometimes we talk to 75 year old
ones and sometimes we talk to 65 year
olds but and there's nothing wrong with
any of it wherever you are is where you
are
the trick is we want you to get about
the business
of winning
and don't believe these hope steelers
that are out there spreading lies
that puts us our the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you